vous l'avez dit essentiellement de la
réjouissance du côté du côté ukrainien
volodime zenenski qui sur Twitter s'en
félicite l'un de ces ministres couliba
également et pour cause c'est la
première fois que l'Europe fournit du
matériel de combat de fabrication
européenne à l'Ukraine jusqu'ici tous
les chars qui avaient été fournis
notamment polonais était de fabrication
soviétique donc c'est c'est une première
pour l'Ukraine et
volodiumski et son gouvernement espère
que cela et bien va ouvrir cette
opportunité cette volonté pour tous les
Occidentaux de leur fournir du matériel
blindé notamment de l'artillerie alors
plusieurs choses il ne s'agit pas en
réalité d'un chat on entend beaucoup
parler de chars bus qui les monté sur
roues mais c'est on va dire
qui est un char d'observation qui est un
véhicule blindé léger d'observation mais
qui permet si jamais il rencontre
l'ennemi une riposte alors plusieurs
éléments on ne sait pas vous l'avez dit
combien de cahicules vont être fournis
et dans quel délai et puis il va falloir
former les âmes c'est pas comme un
véhicule de location que l'on pourrait
conduire du jour non il va falloir
former évidemment les Ukrainiens à
l'utilisation de ces blindés légers il
va falloir fournir également des
munitions puisque ça fonctionne avec des
obus de 105 mm donc il y aura toujours
ce problème des munitions et puis
ensuite deux choses premièrement pour
pouvoir utiliser ces blindés il va
falloir qu'il gèle en Ukraine et pour le
moment les températures sont plutôt
clémentes donc pas de contre-offensif
possible pour les Ukrainiens la deuxième
chose c'est que les Ukrainiens demandent
surtout surtout dans l'urgence une
protection de leur ciel c'est-à-dire des
systèmes de défense entière et là dessus
il y a encore des armes qui manquent
selon le gouvernement de wolo divers
zenenski on rappelle que les États-Unis
ont promis un système de batterie
patriotes de défense du ciel mais il ne
sera pas livré avant au moins un mois et
il faudrait encore 6 mois pour former
les Ukrainiens l'utilisation de ce
système de défense entière